my name is captain fred haas with the
las vegas metropolitan police department
i'm here to give you an update on the
shooting that occurred here on may 30th
2021.
that evening we got reports of shots
fired that a party was occurring inside
the pavilion pool that was attended
between 150 and 200 people inside
during that party several altercations
broke out inside which led to firearms
being pulled and gunfire erupting not
only in this parking lot but inside the
facility
two people sustained injuries
based on that shooting it was trapped in
the woods we're minor in nature however
i want you to look around
you've got a high school
you've got a community center a church
the neighborhood the high school and the
community center both received impacts
as well as the pool facility in total
over 150 rounds were fired in this
parking lot
we have to look today that is
unacceptable by any standard
we will not accept violence in this
community will not accept that type of
behavior in this community we will go to
the end of the earth be relentless in
this investigation
to make sure that doesn't occur again
and the people that did this are held
responsible for their actions
we've obtained indictments for five
individuals for the total of about 50
felony charges
those five individuals
are terrence jefferson
demaria wesley
travon ward
and michael simmons
we've also arrested four other
individuals that were non-related this
investigation the shooting itself
we also have charges pending against the
promoter that held this party
that evening
we need the public's assistance
i need help in finding
michael simmons and cedric sweden they
both have active arrest warrants and are
wanted
if you're out there turn yourselves in
if you know where they're at call crime
stoppers 385-5555
and let us know we can pick them up and
hold them responsible for what they did
here it's unacceptable
this is our community and we have to do
it together
but i need your help i need your
partnership
i need to be part of the solution and
not the problem if you know about
violence whether it's robberies
shootings anything report it to the
police be our partners with this
when we had this investigation there
were no witnesses that came forward
nobody this party called 911 to report a
shooting happened
it's not acceptable
we have to hold people accountable for
this for what they're doing in our
neighborhoods
with that i'll take a few questions
regarding the investigation
the atf was involved in the
investigation how far their
collaboration you don't when you have
that many shell casings that are found
they're a great part with helping get
those processed that is key evidence we
use to help bring these charges forward
how lucky were the people that no more
than two people were injured how bad
could have this been this could be bad
if you think there's 150 to 200 people
that were inside this venue when the
shooting erupted and 150 rounds are
fired i think that's pretty lucky
um that's that's it just
it baffles me that nobody got hurt it
baffles me that we have all these
neighborhoods these churches in this
school
and they chose here
it's not acceptable anywhere in our
community we have to do this together
we have to be part of the community
together to make this happen we have to
be safe was it gang related there are
gangs that are involved in this um
whether that's perceived disrespect um
that's hard to tell at this point of the
investigation when was there a break and
when did the indictments happen or when
did they start coming together this
started coming together about four or
five months into the investigation it
just takes a long time to process this
evidence it is daunting it is tedious
but we want to make sure as much as we
do this correctly and we do the charges
right we bring them to justice what were
the resources like and
how much of a priority was this
implication this investigation touched
several aspects of the department our
central intelligence unit special
investigation section someone area
command the gang unit the city of las
vegas they've all been partners to help
bring these charges together um it was
daunting it was number one priority
until we got to that point of the
indictments
sir how many people have been arrested
of those five three are arrested two are
outstanding and then the fourth has been
arrested on charges that were not
related to the shooting specifically but
were developed through the investigation
thank you guys have a safe day